le conducteur est rentré déjà dans le
premier stop du sommet il n'est plus
réveillé continuer à cligner les yeux et
malgré cela on a pu voir ce centre à c
et g on voir apparaître des signes d'un
endormi
maintenant c'est tellement probants avec
l'absolu mans que vous arrêtiez pour
prochaine un endroit où vous pouvez vous
arrêter vous arrêter
grâce à ce micro émetteur de l'aspect
n'at on va recueillir le courant chaud
les électrodes que j'ai placé sur le
corps les transformer en ondes
radioélectriques et saison des biens
vont partir de la voiture lequel je suis
au volant pour aller en direction d'une
autre voiture sur lequel on va
enregistrer tout cela en quelque sorte
on fait ce qu'on appelle de la
télémesure un peu ce qui se passe à bord
du skylab où les astronautes sont suivis
en permanence depuis le sol alors qu'ils
sont en vol autour de la terre
le but de l'opération est bien je vous
le rappelle c'est de déceler dans des
conditions réelles
l'apparition du sommeil au volant d'une
automobile et sauf vous verrez au bout
de très peu de kilomètres
là c'est ici que tout qui vient de votre
cerveau va être enregistrées de votre
corps tout est très important
ici vous avez le rythme cardiaque même
au mouvement des yeux horizontaux droite
gauche pour garder ce côté là vous avez
les clignements des yeux signes de
fatigue bien sûr là votre activité du
cerveau on savoir si votre chapeau et
réveiller ou bien si l'or est là
l'activité de vos muscles du menton
actuellement est en train de mâcher ça
sera très bien
plus ça va au plus l'autre conducteur
est en train de plier les yeux très
fréquemment ce qui est déjà un premier
signe de fatigue
alors comment ça va
un peu fatiguée un peu fatigué parce que
pour nous c'est absolument évident que
vous avez non seulement beaucoup cligner
des yeux ce qui veut dire qu'on m'avait
pas vu la moitié du chemin rapidement
mais encore votre tracé a mis en
évidence les endormissement je vais déjà
dépassé le stade de l'éveil les yeux
fermés pratiquement c'est à dire que je
dormais les yeux ouverts j'étais en
train de dormir les yeux ouverts on sait
très bien que il est possible d'être
réveillé parfaitement relayé sur le plan
du comportement d'avoir un cerveau
endormi c'est donc une dissociation très
importante qui peut donner le change aux
personnes qui se trouvent dans la
voiture mais dans son cas soit très
rapidement soit par l'observation soit
par exemple par exemple enregistrements
comme nous allons le faire avec grande
quantité de clignement qui ont disparu
lorsqu'on vous appeler